we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a caller this is our biblical
prophecy caller
she's called in many times over the
years and she analogizes
the news into biblical prophecy in a way
that for me
is completely disconnected from reality
and uh
irrelevant but it's still interesting
apparently biden defeating trump has
thrown
biblical prophecy into chaos take a
listen to this
i i have bad news for you um i felt for
a long time
that uh bush was the right around the
fiery red horse obama was right around
the dark wars
right in revelations apocalypse four
horsemen
chapter six and that trump is the writer
on the pale horse
and because he lost the election hades
follows close behind
cities is biden i think he wants a war
against israel
um because he ran with obama
and so he would be pro
pro uh islam and um
uh i think he's going to kill christians
and hunger and beast
and death coveted and something else
that i can't remember
yeah so whatever that that goes on for
two more minutes so
so that listen i mean that that's a
framework that's a framework and i know
that it's easy to laugh it off but
that's a framework that actually
appeals to a lot of people in the united
states seeing things through that lens i
think it's
completely counterproductive beyond just
not being based in fact but i do
for some reason i find it fast like i
find that call fascinating i think
the pale horse and killing christians
i i am fascinated that that is a
framework that some people find uh find
reasonable but you know
to each their own as i say uh let's
remind you that we have a tremendous
bonus bonus show
oh boy we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today we will talk about a
trump donor wanting his money back
and much much more get instant access to
the
i have to be careful here bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com